[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As a
developer, it can be
difficult to get started
with new cloud technologies.
Whether you're looking
to deploy a web app,
set up a new database, or
run big data workloads,
it's often challenging to find
the right materials to help
you get up and running.
This is where Google Cloud
quickstarts come into play.
Quickstarts are quick
step-by-step tutorials
to help you get started with
new Google Cloud products.
They typically cover
basic use cases, like how
to make your first API call or
deploy your first hello world
application.
Quickstarts can cover several
different ways of interacting
with Google Cloud products.
First, some quickstarts
show you how
to get things done from
the Google Cloud Console.
This is where you can manage
your cloud resources directly
from a web portal.
You can do things like
create new compute engine
virtual machine instances,
set up new databases,
and check on the status
of deployed apps.
You can also create
new projects,
set up billing, and
manage permissions.
Second, there are
quickstarts that
show you how to use Google
Cloud command line tools,
like G Cloud, gsutil
and BQ, all of which
are part of the
Google Cloud SDK.
G Cloud is a command
line tool that
allows you to do things
like create compute engine
virtual machine instances,
deploy web apps to App Engine,
and set up Google
kubernetes engine clusters.
Gsutil is the command
line tool that
allows you to interact
with cloud storage.
You can do things like create
new buckets, upload file
objects and download
file objects.
BQ is a command line tool for
interacting with BigQuery,
Google Cloud's enterprise
data warehouse designed
to help you ingest, store,
analyze and visualize big data.
And finally, we have
quickstarts that
show you how to interact
with Google Cloud via code
using our client libraries.
These quickstarts include
instructions and sample code
for programming languages,
like Python, node.js, Go, Java,
Ruby, PHP, C-sharp, and C++.
Let's take a look at
an example quickstart
for the Cloud Vision
API, which provides you
insights about your images using
the power of machine learning.
First, there's the
Before You Begin section,
which shows you how to do
common tasks before you
use any product, such as
setting up a new project,
enabling billing, and
managing authentication.
Next, you learn how to install
the Cloud Vision API client
library for the programming
language of your choice.
And finally, there are
pieces of sample code
in different
programming languages
to show you how to use the
client libraries to call
the Cloud Vision API via code.
For Python, you can just
copy and paste this code
into a new file called
main.py and run Python main.py
from your command
line interface.
So where can you find
these quickstart tutorials?
You can find our full
collection of quickstarts
at cloud.google.com
/docs/quickstarts.
Quickstarts are easy to find
in our product documentation.
Here in the Cloud Vision
API documentation,
there's a section in
the left navigation
bar for quickstart tutorials.
And finally, we also have video
versions of these quickstarts,
where we walk you through how to
get started with various Google
Cloud products.
Check out the links in
the description below.
And there you have it.
Quickstarts are
easy-to-use tutorials
that show you step-by-step
how to get started.
Make sure to click
the like button
and subscribe to the channel for
more getting started content.
We're excited to
see what you build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]